[Music] hey everybody thank you
so much for being here we're so
blessed you could be here be honest
you're hoping that it's blue right
as long as our baby is healthy we're
gonna be happy all right hey here we go
uh-huh
it's yellow your baby is a libertarian
what I'm gonna go here look at the ultrasounds
that's the head and that's the foot and that's a
baggie of magic mushrooms and that is a pamphlet
on jury nullification is this fetus flipping off
the camera yeah it didn't like that we were
taking pictures of it without a warrant I
don't understand it's not Republican or Democrat
yeah which way is it supposed to vote uh it may
not God God what kind of God would do this to
a loving family did we do something wrong is it
our fault Libertarians can come from all sorts of
households left and right so it's half Republican
half Democrat God damn political hermaphrodite
now hang on I'm libertarian and I'm fine
right um well that's hurtful what kind of 24-hour
news is it gonna watch it's it's Chick-fil-A okay
what about Ben and Jerry's is it gonna hate
Disney because of the gay inclusion or the
corporate profit I don't even know what sign to
put in our yard you're not actually gonna let it
be libertarian right what do you mean the lettuce
in this political climate you might as well throw
your baby away in this political climate throwing
a baby away is illegal to be clear it's always
been illegal to throw a baby away pretty sure
California is still an option if you're quick
about it nobody's throwing away any babies oh so
it's a protest baby probably not a good gift right
honey are you crying you know you could probably
exchange it for Bitcoin baby the book although
in a truly capitalist Society you should be oh
my God this again everybody listen up yes we're
having a non-binary child and yes it's gonna be
a monster we all invariably blame the downfall of
democracy on because it spoils the election
for the good party my party my part my part
either way this is technically our child and we
are going to love this political Quasimodo and
hope that someday an Evangelical youth group or
a sneering University indoctrination forces it
to pick a lane but until then we just need some
time to process what's happened to our family
and maybe start digging a nursery bunker
all right let's give him some space so is
it a boy or it's definitely a boy obviously
it's probably going to come
out with a beer [Music]